- [Mark] So, Stone.
- [Stone] Yes, sir.
- [Mark] Welcome back.
- [Stone] Hey, what's going
on, Mark, how you doing?
- [Mark] What you got in your hand there?
- Hey, look here, man,
I seen this little item right here, man.
It brought back some cold memories for me.
Hands of Stone actually
was reactivating this.
What I remember mostly about these,
somebody owed my folks money,
and I've come through with the small ones.
They used to have a
little Louisville Slugger,
they used to give it at the
opening day at Dodger's Stadium.
It was wood about the same size,
probably about the same,
probably a little smaller in this area.
But what I used to like about it most,
is when you walk up, they can't see him.
And then when you come
up, you pull it out.
You don't have to hit him in
the face or nothing like that.
It's about some money.
So when you get at them,
you say bah, bah, them knees,
they automatically fall.
And the cold part about that,
they going to remember that
for about three, four months after that.
It's a cold, cold thing,
but it'll get the message.
So when somebody else see that
dude limping down the street
they'll be like, oh, he must
have owed such and such money.
So it's like sending a message
to all the people that
the loan sharks are doing.
That that's what's going to happen to you
if you don't pay me my money.
And once we started doing that
it didn't take a whole lot of people.
After three or four people walk around,
hobbling around people was
paying they money on time.
Some people was even paying
it a couple of nights earlier.
But one time, man
it was a little cat that
wanted to be, you know
he wanted to be a part of our little crew,
what we was doing.
'Cause we had separated ourselves
from everybody else that was hanging out,
and he was like, nah, man, I'm waiting.
Put me on, put me on.
I ended up,
where I was from
(indistinct) if we put that out there.
But where I was from,
I ended up making him my little homeboy.
And he started claiming my
neighborhood and everything.
But the little dude, man,
he was probably about 19 years old, man.
And he really wanted to hang out with us.
You know what I'm saying?
And I'm like, alright, go let
him see, see what he can do.
He wasn't no big old dude either.
That's why I was tripping off of him.
But the dude go.
He was like, man, you
owe such such money, man.
You supposed to be paying.
And I'm like, you know,
I ain't saying that I'm
just looking at him.
And he like man, you got the money?
And the boy was like,
man, I'm going to pay you,
and he fired on him.
And after he hit him,
my homie had the bat.
He run, snatched the bat from him,
and just kicked up all
in the dude's head, man.
I grabbed this little dude,
man, hold up man, hold up man.
He's like, no, he's
going to pay that money.
And he had zoned out so
bad that when he went out
you couldn't even send him by himself.
You know, sorry to say,
but this little kid
right now got life, man.
But that's what he was doing, man.
Any situation he was in
I don't know what was
going in his head man,
but he is zoned out
and it was all murder, death,
kill with him. For anything.
And you know, I put him
on my turf, you know,
the homies loved him and all
that because he was an idiot.
But you know, I really still
kind of feel kind of bad, man.
I still write dude, time to time, man.
You know, I ain't got no
whole bunch, but you know,
probably once every
like three, four months
I might shoot him like 30, 40 bucks
get you a case of soups or something,
you know what I'm saying?
'Cause I remember him before
he turned into what he was.
I mean, I ain't gonna go
all in no guilt with myself
but you know, that's
what it was out there.
You know?
I didn't seen him do some
stuff on his own where, I mean,
I don't know what I, I'm
trying to keep it where,
you know, Dragnet say?
Names are changed to protect the innocent.
Yeah, man, I seen (indistinct)
set this tent on fire, man.
But folks was in there asleep, right.
And we all, you know,
I think he was owing $100 or something
dude was supposed to owe.
He was like, man, let me go get it.
So they go and I guess
they in a cocaine coma
because he's banging on the
tent, banging on the tent,
and don't nobody answer.
He strike out and run down
the street, come back.
He come back, banging on their tent again.
Don't nobody know what he doing
but he got some lighter fluid in his hand
and he knocking on the
tent, all around the tent,
but he's sprinkling a
lighter fluid on the tent.
And he said, oh, you
ain't going to wake up?
He took a match and struck it.
And poof.
And it immediately, you
know, that's plastic
and immediately go up in flames, right?
And it was a dude and a female in there,
and they woke up, and the tent,
I think went up and like
probably about 10, 15 seconds.
Whole tent engulfed in flames.
When they come running out,
the dude came out first.
I don't know if you know anything
about that plastic on them
tents and the zippers.
If it's on fire, you're not
going to find the zipper.
So when he come running
out bam with the first one,
he went out, the plastic,
stuck on him still.
So when he ran out, he come out
the front of him was all on fire.
They have to rolled him on the ground.
And a little dude still went
and tried to get the money from him.
He was all in his pocket and everything.
Yeah. I think about
some of that stuff, man,
and I thank God today,
man, I'm still here.
You know what I'm saying?
That's why today I do try and help folks.
You know, I'm like, you know,
he ain't done with me yet.
I still got my character faults, man.
But I really think about
stuff before I do it today.
And I think if what if that
was my cousin or my uncle.
So that's why a lot
of stuff I don't get myself caught up in.
You know, I'm still who I am.
You know what I'm saying?
You know, I might even get drunk out here
and say cuss a few times,
but for the most part,
man, I look at it, man ,
I don't even see it work for
you, know what I'm saying?
I think I...
Well I'm going to bring
you back a little bit, man.
'82, '83
we was really turned up
before I came out here.
I think I came out here like '87, '88.
A lot of my older homeboys had got life
and dudes just coming home now
like '82, 1983, '84.
The year I graduated was '84.
So basically for the most
part of my, my era, I'm 53,
Most of the kids,
'cause a lot of them got
life in my neighborhood.
So like '84 to '88,
them dudes is just coming home now,
whole life gone.
They whole mentality,
everything is still prison.
And you know, I did a few years in there.
I didn't really do no long stretch.
And I look at the way I think now
and the way they think,
I mean I was well on my way to that,
but wow, it's just crazy.
Their whole, this right here,
is foreign to them really.
They feel more at home in there,
be like, man, this just regular stuff.
You know, I thank God every night, man,
that I didn't have to go through that.
And I don't think I could do a day, bro.
So for the most part I do
keep myself straight, man.
- [Mark] You grew up in South central?
- [Rock] Yes I did.
- [Mark] And what do you see the problem
with like that community,
and so many families are broken.
- [Rock] It's real easy.
For the most part,
I'm gonna take it back to me, 53.
Uncles, aunties, everybody, like they say,
it takes a village to raise a child.
The drug epidemic came,
basically what when Oliver
North went over there,
with Noriega, with Bush CIA.
Anyway--
- [Mark] But crack hit
the black communities
really hard, right?
- [Rock] Our mentors and
roll models started off,
when I was young,
they was players,
it was a rich man high,
to smoke cocaine.
So then, you know, everybody
wants to be players, boss,
you know, as it progressed
cause you never baskets,
but none of that shit,
man, when I was young.
But for the most part, all those dudes
they're the ones that
ended up getting rich
are gone to jail for life became these
pushing baskets.
And then a young kid,
if you're not respecting your mother,
your father, your uncles, your aunties
half of them raised by the grandmother
who's too old to actually
really do anything
or put any real discipline down,
I'm just on this trip because
I'm a grandparent today too.
My grandson really can't
do too much wrong, anyway.
And I tell his mama, don't hit that boy,
you know what I'm saying?
But if they ain't got nobody to respect
or nobody to look to for no
guidance on what it should be,
what do you think is going to happen?
If they run around, if
mom's taking the food stamps
and smoking them up with the dope, man
there ain't no food in the house.
How was he going to respect her?
Now, if he don't respect his mama,
the fuck you think he gonna respect you?
So it all starts back.
I mean it begins with drugs
and ends with drugs, man.
- [Mark] In the families?
- I mean, I don't want to go too far,
but for the most part I
think they knew that too.
It's fucked up.
But I mean now it's a lot better
that this generation that's coming up now,
like they say in the Bible,
there's going to be wiser, but weaker.
They smart as hell.
Know how to use phones
and computers at one and two years old.
A lot of them don't
believe in God, you know.
Don't make sense their
computer and all that
but it's not as much crack.
And the parents are more at home now.
So I don't think the next
generation is going to be as bad
as these.
Because these kids, they
didn't have nothing,
they didn't have to respect nothing.
So what do you expect them
to come out and respect
on the streets?
If you don't have to respect your mama,
see, I had to respect my mother.
If I disrespect my mother,
I have about four uncles,
they might not all come the same day,
but they coming to get that ass.
Pops didn't stay at the house,
he's coming to get that ass.
And mom's going to get that ass.
So I got about seven,
eight whoopers coming
for disrespecting my mom.
These kids, they slapping their mamas
and calling them bitches.
So if they going to do that
to the person that raised him
what do you think he
cared about anything else?
So, you know, it's got to start over.
We got to start all over
from the fabric, man.
But that's my take home.
That's a wrap.
- [Mark] Thank you so
much for talking to me
and sharing your stories.
Thank you, man.